[Musik]
weltbank und iwf schlagen alarm die
schuldenblase bedrohe immer mehr die
weltwirtschaft seit mitte der 90er hat
sich die schuldenlast von staaten banken
firmen und bürgern vervierfacht 1996
liegt der schuldenstand der
industrieländer noch bei 56 billionen
us-dollar und 7 millionen gehen auf das
konto der entwicklungs und
schwellenländer
zehn jahre später 2006 sind es schon
mehr als doppelt so viel
bis 2019 steigen die schulden auf 180
millionen in den industrieländern und 70
millionen in den entwicklungs und
schwellenländern
laut orf sind das summa summarum 250
millionen us dollar schulden die sich
rund um den globus aufgetürmt haben und
dann kommt noch corona dazu hunderte von
milliarden euro neuschulden allein in
deutschland und dann die hilfspakete der
europäischen union rettungsaktionen rund
um den globus die welt verschuldet sich
wie nie zuvor in der geschichte
da stellt sich schon die frage droht
nach corona der finanzkraft
was bedeutet das für uns für die junge
generation eines ist schon mal sicher
die schwarze null an der wir so lange
festgehalten haben ist vom tisch
es gab zwar kritik im detail aber nicht
am schuldenmachen
zu jahresbeginn lief sie noch rückwärts
jetzt tickt die schuldenuhr des
steuerzahlerbundes montag in die andere
richtung
mit dem riesen konjunkturpaket der
bundesregierung dürfte sich die
geschwindigkeit noch deutlich erhöhen
wir wollen mit wumms aus der krise
kommen wir versuchen aus dieser extrem
schwierigen situation gemeinsam stark
heraus zu kommen dabei waren wir nicht
ängstlich sondern mutig aber auch nicht
tollkühn 130 milliarden euro kostet das
konjunkturpaket dazu kommen noch die
rund 150 milliarden der bislang
beschlossenen hilfspaket
es sind gigantische summen die die
schuldenquote deutschlands wohl von 60
auf 80 prozent steigen lässt die lasten
werden andere tragen müssen
aus sicht der kommenden generation davon
sich große sorgen machen denn das ist
ein der größte ungedeckte schecks den
wir alle zu unseren lebzeiten hier
erlebt haben und das ist sicherlich
nicht besonders generationengerecht und
doch eine schuldenquote von 80 prozent
ist im internationalen vergleich eher
harmlos frankreich wird wohl auf 115
prozent kommen
die usa auf 130 italien auf 155 und
japan gar auf 250 prozent
schauen sie die usa die haben
schuldenquote von weit über 100 prozent
schauen sie nach japan die haben 250
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts und
haben auch kein problem mit ihrer
schuldentragfähigkeit weil das wachstum
stimmt weil die zinsen niedrig sind und
da ist deutschland mit seinen 60 oder
vielleicht bald 80 prozent noch in einer
sehr komfortablen situation
und dass die union den ökonomen gefolgt
ist ist die größte überraschung selbst
das selbst gesetzte limit von 100
milliarden euro wurde gerissen
jahrelang waren schwarze null und die
schuldenbremse ein fetisch von cdu und
csu mit der immensen neuverschuldung
bricht auch eine der letzten
konservativen pfeiler der unionsparteien
weg union und spd wollen die wirtschaft
retten mit gigantischen summen
jetzt wird scharf geschossen mit
raketenwerfern und war super
voller euro so der finanzminister wie
viele blogger kamen sie dennoch herr
scholz hat keinen guten tag und nach
allem was man weiß nur eine bazooka die
große frage ist ob das reicht wie kaum
einem finanzminister zuvor brechen olaf
scholz die einnahmen weg der abgrund in
denen die steuerschätzer geblickt haben
ist noch tiefer als in der finanzkrise
nachdem die steuereinnahmen von bund
ländern und gemeinden über jahre
gestiegen waren frist corona alles
wieder auf minus 98,6 milliarden euro
die schätzung für dieses jahr statt
steuereinnahmen macht die politik
schulden es ist eine riskante wette auf
die zukunft
wir sind in frankfurt einmal den banken
zentrum europas
hier wird das geld das wir nicht haben
gehandelt
wir wollen herausfinden ob die bitte gut
ausgehen kann
wir treffen drei experten
einen führenden wirtschafts und
finanzwissenschaftler der die
bundesregierung berät eine börsen
journalisten die schon live von der wall
street und über die finanzkrise 2008
berichtete und einen ehemaligen
investmentbanker der jetzt eine finanz
wende fordert der professor wieland
machen sie sich sorgen wegen der hohen
verschuldung ja natürlich
die schuld verschuldung ist zwar
notwendig schuldenquoten auch für
deutschland können jetzt in diesem und
nächsten jahr 20 30 prozent steigen
aber diese schulden müssen wir natürlich
auch tragen können und im moment hilft
die ezb kauft in großem stil
staatsanleihen aber langfristig auch
wenn die zinsen steigen müssen die
mitgliedstaaten der währungsunion diese
schulden auch bedienen können die zinsen
zahlen können und dazu müssen wir
wachsen dazu müssen die staaten
steuereinnahmen haben aus wachstum nicht
aus steuererhöhungen um diese schulden
auch bedienen zu können und letztlich
sie auch wieder zu reduzieren
die verschuldungs fähigkeit eines
staates ist ja nicht begrenzt wie beim
sommer privathaushalt durch den
einkommen oder sondern es geht im
prinzip darum dass der staat seine
schulden nicht zurückzahlt genauso wenig
unternehmen übrigens sondern wenn die
schulden fällig werden macht der staat
eine anschlussfinanzierung leiht sich
wieder geld am kapitalmarkt
das heißt die die begrenzung des staates
sich zu verschulden nicht da wo in
keiner mehr geld leiht das ist aber
keine feste zahl sondern das richtet
sich nach allen möglichen umstimmen
also normalerweise gemessen wird das ja
als in prozent vom bruttosozialprodukt
wir waren bei 60 vor der pandemie und
sind jetzt nach dem panini maßnahmen bei
72 des bruttosozialprodukts das ist sehr
sehr niedrig im oecd-vergleich japan hat
zb 240 prozent und hat eigentlich keine
probleme sich am kapitalmarkt
finanzieren kann eine hohe verschuldung
wie das jetzt der fall ist durch die
korona dieses zu einem finanz crash
führen
das ist zumindest ein risiko weil
natürlich jetzt sowohl banken aber auch
staaten sehr sehr hohe schulden eingehen
die schulden steigen auch die
schuldenquoten relativ zur
wirtschaftsleistung steigen sowohl für
die staaten als auch für die
privatwirtschaft
aber ist es nicht so jetzt als lang so
viele schulden müssen doch zurückbezahlt
wird
oder müssen die schulden am ende gar
nicht zurückbezahlen werden da gibt es
auch solche und solche fraktionen ich
meine wenn sie so welcher gehören sie
dass ich bin der meinung die müssen
nicht zurückgezahlt werden
derweil weil die verschuldungs fähigkeit
des staates hält davon abhängt ob er
sich immer wieder neues geld leiten kann
man bringt immer dieses beispiel von der
schwäbischen hausfrau die schwäbische
hausfrau muss natürlich auch meiner
ansicht nach an
ihre ihre verbindlichkeiten regeln warum
weil sie stirbt staaten sterben aber
nicht genauso wenig wie großunternehmen
nicht sterben teilen da stirbt nicht
volkswagenstiftung deswegen zahlen die
auch ihre schulden nicht zurück sondern
es kommt immer darauf an das geld das
das dass das unternehmen schuldet zu
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt ersetzen zu
können durch neues geld so wie sie das
machen ist eine andere frage aber ob sie
es schaffen oder nicht davon hängt
weitere existenz grundvoraussetzung dass
es zu keinem kreis kommt ist dass wir
auch langfristig wieder
wirtschaftswachstum haben dass die
staaten ihre schulden bezahlen können
aber dass auch die unternehmen ihre
schulden bezahlen können und das können
sie dann wenn es wachstum gibt dann
können sie auch zinsen zahlen auch
wieder neue schulden begeben das ist
entscheidend
ich glaube dass einem schon etwas
unheimlich werden kann wenn man sieht
wie viele billionen da gerade in die
wirtschaft gepumpt werden andererseits
befürchte ich dass es fast keine andere
möglichkeit gab ich glaube das ist sehr
sehr wichtig war sowohl unternehmen aber
auch den verbrauchern zu signalisieren
so wir krempeln jetzt die ärmel hoch und
wir unterstützen die wirtschaft wir
geben einfach unser bestes whatever it
takes ja das ist ja auch ein spruch der
immer wieder kam alles was nötig ist um
einfach für vertrauen wieder in der
wirtschaft zu sorgen und vertrauen ist
in so einer krise enorm wichtig in der
korona krise spielen die notenbanken
eine entscheidende rolle so auch die
europäische zentralbank in frankfurt
hinter nehmen die ezb hat erfahrung mit
verschuldeten ländern in der eurozone zb
mit griechenland und italien
sie kauft dann staatsanleihen sie kauft
sozusagen die schulden der staaten um
die konjunktur zu stützen und die
währung zu stabilisieren
jetzt mit der korona krise kauft sie so
viele staatsanleihen wie nie zuvor in
der geschichte und das geht per
mausklick in sekundenschnelle
die ortszeit an den wichtigsten
handelsplätzen der welt immer im blick
katja hitler arbeitet als portfolio
managerin bei der europäischen
zentralbank
sie und ihre kollegen setzen die
geldpolitik der ezb in die praxis um
das heißt vor allem viel geld ausgeben
die habe ich jetzt mit zehnjährigen
deutschen staatsanleihe ausgesucht ich
gucke mir den preis am markt an den sich
auf dem bildschirm und dann gebe ich ein
betrag den ich gerne kaufen würde
jetzt können wir mal 20 millionen zum
beispiel kaufen und damit der preis dann
gefällt dann und der niedrig genug ist
für uns dann kaufe ich die anleihe mit
wenigen mausklicks hat sie für die ezb
staatsanleihen im wert von 20 millionen
euro gekauft und damit neues geld
geschaffen gekauft werden die papiere
nach der größe der euro länder also am
meisten deutsche staatsanleihen und nur
solche bei denen das ausfallrisiko
gering ist
ständig hat katja hitler daher die
marktentwicklung im blick gucken was
machen die märkte wie verhalten sie sich
in welchem moment kaufe ich am besten
die anleihen vormittags oder nachmittags
dann die koordination im euro system
nimmt einen sehr großen anteil an
das heißt die nationalen zentralbanken
kaufen auch staatsanleihen und wir
koordinieren
wer wie viel von welchem starts an einem
tag kaufte das ist ein ganz großer
bestandteil von dem was wir am tag
machen
auf diese weise hat die 40-jährige schon
milliarden bewegt seit 2015 hat die ezb
die geldschleusen weit geöffnet damals
startete der kauf von anleihen in großem
stil
mittlerweile sitzt die zentralbank auf
einem berg von staatspapieren im wert
von mehr als 2,1 millionen euro
alles für das ziel die inflation
anzukurbeln richtung zwei prozent
eine medizin mit nebenwirkungen die
staaten profitieren sie kommen günstig
an frisches geld und machen noch mehr
schulden kritisieren experten
doch die anleihekäufe gehen unvermindert
weiter
monat für monat kommen 20 milliarden
euro obendrauf eine gigantische summe
der ezb rat würde sobald die
inflationsentwicklung den vorstellungen
des ezb-rats entspricht das heißt wir
haben preisniveaustabilität wenn die
inflation knapp unter zwei prozent im
jahr steigt und sobald das erreicht wird
wird der ezb rat darüber nachdenken die
anleihe ankäufer einzustellen
waren diese situation allerdings
eintritt ist überhaupt noch nicht
abzusehen
mit der korona krise befürchtet die ezb
einen beispiellosen konjunktureinbruch
deshalb greift sie so massiv in den
finanzmarkt ein und zwar seit dem 4
juni dieses jahres an jenem tag trat die
ezb präsidentin christine lagarde vor
die weltpresse und verkündete ein
notprogramm von insgesamt 1,3 millionen
euro
ernste mienen in der europäischen
zentralbank und das vor leeren rängen
präsidentin christine lagarde begründet
die drastischen maßnahme mit einem
wirtschaftseinbruch der weitaus stärker
sei als erwartet
incoming information unsere
informationen bestätigen dass die
wirtschaft in der eurozone ein bisschen
nie dagewesenen einbruch erlebt dieser
ab ob der absturz ist folge der korona
virus pandemie und der maßnahmen die
unternommen wurden um sie einzudämmen
durch den einbruch ist die
inflationsrate im euroraum von 1,4
prozent im januar drastisch auf nur noch
0,1 prozent im mai gesunken weil die ezb
aber knapp zwei prozent anpeilt musste
sie jetzt erneut handeln
es gibt der notenbanken die gerade jetzt
auch geld drucken
welchen effekt hat hast ja praktisch
druckt die notenbank geld im moment sie
trug kein papiergeld aber sie schafft
geld indem sie den banken vermögenswerte
abkauft also staatsanleihen
unternehmensanleihen von banken
abgekauft und ihnen liquidität
letztendlich einen höheren betrag auf
dem konto dass die bank bei der
notenbank hat zur verfügung stellt im
moment schafft dieses geld keine
inflation weil wir in einer krise in der
rezession sind aber wenn sie diese
politik zwei drei vier jahre weiter
fährt dann steigen natürlich die
geldmenge stark an und schafft dass
inflationen dann muss sie auch wieder
die zinsen erhöhen und die staats- und
lagerbestände zurückführen
inwieweit können wir sicher sein dass
dieses viele geld tatsächlich auch
investition fließt im moment den dieses
geld haupt sich dazu zu stützen also
werte zu stützen und das heißt dass die
unternehmen
die ezb unternehmensanleihen zb kauft
oder wenn die banken den unternehmen
kredit geben dann müssen die unternehmen
ihre investitionen nicht so stark
zurückführen
das heißt es stützt aber für die zukunft
und um investitionen zu erhöhen oder in
die zukunft zu tätigen müssen natürlich
auch die gewinnmöglichkeiten in der
zukunft gut sein und das heißt da muss
eine wachstumschance entstehen und
sozusagen profitmöglichkeiten für
investoren da es seien erst dann führt
das zu einem anstieg der investitionen
in der zukunft sie haben eine bestimmte
menge des zentralbank geldes das die ezb
schafft und auf dieser basis entsteht
banken geld und das ist erst mal die
basis für inflation die zweite frage ist
dieses banken geld muss ja auch in
umlauf das heißt wenn es keiner
nachfragt gebe es auch keine inflation
und ich wüsste jetzt nicht wo jetzt
inflation herkommen sollte also wir
haben jetzt diese situation mit der
pandemie
die leute werden sicherlich nicht
loslaufen und sich langlebige
konsumgüter kaufen sprich waschmaschinen
küchen und so weiter wie die
wahnsinnigen weil sie gelernt haben hey
das erzählt uns wie man da kann eine
zweite welle kommen dann bin ich wieder
auf kurzarbeit mit 70 der halte ich
lieber mein geld zusammen also auf der
seite passiert ist das zweite was immer
brauchen für inflation ist eine lohn
lohn lohn explosion sozusagen also
starke erhöhungen der arbeitskosten die
dann die betriebe weiter geben über ihre
preise so entsteht inflation
wo soll das herkommen ja wir haben im
moment diese ganzen leute in kurzarbeit
es gibt leute die gehen davon aus dass
von den leuten die in kurzarbeit sind
eine million langzeitarbeitslos werden
also ich sehe jetzt nicht wo irgendein
irgendeiner form einen druck auf die
löhne herkommen sollte und wie soll dann
inflation entstehen
die notenbanken haben ja durch ihre
niedrigzinspolitik schon seit jahren die
aktienkurse enorm gestützt also sind die
zinsen niedrig werden andere
anlageoptionen eher unattraktiv da also
wenn man für eine anleihe wenig zinsen
bekommt dann greift man vielleicht eher
zur aktie weil weil da mehr gewinne zu
erwarten
insofern sind die die notenbanken die
zum beispiel ja auch starken das dürfen
sie offiziell natürlich so nicht sagen
aber wenn sie staatsanleihen kaufen dann
sorgen wir dafür dass staaten günstiger
an kredite kommen und sich günstiger
geld leihen können und das ist natürlich
in krisenzeiten enorm wichtig geld weil
die staaten sicher schrecklich
verschulden müssen in zeiten von corona
und die notenbanken kaufen mittlerweile
ja auch anleihen von unternehmen das ist
sehr umstritten aber am ende hilft das
dem unternehmen natürlich auch es gibt
im moment so eine art ja zeitenwende
wird so viel gesagt aber eine evolution
des denkens in der ökonomie somit dass
sie das dass das dass das war jahrelang
sehr ordoliberale ist das wort dafür
motto liberal und und tradition der
konservativ so wie ich auch an der uni
ausgebildet worden bin gemacht haben
das verändert sich inzwischen zu einem
verständnis das ist mehr eine art
politische ökonomie gibt wo als mosaik
auch darauf ankommt wer sind die akteure
wüsten macht verteilt und so was ist vom
frühjahr hat man das meer
ich übertreibe ich jetzt aber früher hat
man das meer technokratisch gesehen wie
eine wie ingenieurswissenschaften ja
also wenn ich jetzt hier drehe dann
passiert das da und wenn ich da was
mache dann passiert dass da alles super
und man hat jetzt gelernt das natürlich
sehr viel davon abhängt wer sind
eigentlich die akteure welche macht
haben die wir können die einwirken ja
und ich finde das sehr viel vernünftiger
ihren standpunkt als den vor 20 jahren
nochmal dass sie in andere leute anders
aber ja ich bin ich bin sehr sehr
zufrieden mit dem aktionen muss was die
ezb macht ich finde das sehr ordentlich
der bulle und der bär das sind die
beiden symbole der frankfurter börse der
bär steht für den abschwung der macht
seine geschäfte mit der katastrophe
der bulle steht für den aufschwung der
macht seine geschäfte mit der hoffnung
wer von beiden hat das sagen
eines steht fest die börse ist selbst
ein unternehmen und die hat mitten in
der korona krise enorme gewinne
eingefahren
nur vorstand und aufsichtsrat sind
angetreten zur virtuellen
hauptversammlung der deutschen börse ag
die aktionäre können von zu hause zu
schauen ihr unternehmen profitiert von
der korona krise selten zuvor waren
unsere dienste so gefragt das ergebnis
unserer erlöse wuchsen im ersten quartal
um 27% nettoerlöse und unsere gewinne
und 33 prozent die deutsche börse
verdient am regen handel viele aktionäre
hatten zum beginn der korona krise
aktien verkauft später dann wieder
zugekauft so war im märz mit 300
milliarden euro
das handelsvolumen an der deutschen
börse doppelt so hoch wie im
vorjahresmonat
der bass werden momentan viel achsen
viele derivate als viele wertpapiere
gehandelt und wenn viel gehandelt wird
profitiert eine deutsche börse von jedem
einzelnen handel durch die durch eine
gebühr und wenn viele handeln summieren
sich natürlich die sieben gebühren zu
einer grosse gebühr und das ist genau
das was im moment profitiert das zeigt
sich auch am kurs der aktie
die deutsche börse ag erholte sich nach
dem ersten corona schock information der
bulle symbol für optimismus an der börse
ist zurück die korona krise führte zu
einer enormen bewegung an der börse hier
warum eigentlich
ich glaube die base hat sich
mittlerweile total abgekoppelt von von
der echten welt na wir haben enorme
kurssprünge hier erlebt und neue rekorde
gesehen an der börse um das macht im
prinzip gar keinen sinn auf der einen
seite hat man totale angst davor dass
wir hier die schlimmste rezession seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg erleben und auf
der anderen seite feiern feiern die
börsen rekorde warum ist das so weil die
börsen darauf setzen
jetzt geht's erst mal bergab aber es
wird auch ganz schnell wieder bergauf
gehen und die börsen gucken in die
zukunft und rechnet damit dass schon
alles wieder gut
wer sind die gewinner der krise ich muss
leider sagen die 1 prozent reichsten das
stand nicht selber ich hatte das so
nicht erwartet auch nicht kann es auch
immer noch nicht erklären ehrlich gesagt
aber das vermögen der großen milliardär
ist fast 50 milliarden gestiegen seit
die korona krise ausgebrochen ist
und das hängt damit zusammen dass die
börsen jahr eingebrochen sind nach dem
nach dem ausbruch und da war gab es halt
viele möglichkeiten in vermögenswerte zu
investieren die die auch der kunst haben
und jetzt die mobile erstaunlicherweise
haben sich die börsen ja fast wieder auf
vorkrisenniveau erholt
und ja da ist viel geld verdienen worden
und das verdient natürlich nur leute die
auf vermögenswerte halten und 40 prozent
der deutschen bevölkerung haben keine
vermögenswerte oder mehr schulden als
vermögen also die sind bei der party
nicht dabei gewesen so zu sein als die
korona krise nach europa schwappte und
die kurse in den keller rauschen
waren sie auch börsen reporterin können
sich an moment erinnert
jetzt drängen oder wie haben sie das
erlebt ich bin grundsätzlich sowieso
optimist ich habe aber auch in den
vielen krisen gelernt dinge erlebt haben
die base hat noch jede krise überlebt
also irgendwie kommen wir da durch das
ist nur eine frage der zeit das geht
entweder schneller oder es dauert
einfach ein bisschen länger aber wir
packen das das war eine völlig das ist
mir bei jeder krise klar uns hat ja auch
bestimmt das ist die verrückteste aktien
rally gewesen die ich je erlebt habe
draußen irgendwie die totale
verzweiflung und die großen großen
sorgen vor der größten rezession seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg und darin wurden
rekorde gefeiert dass das passte am
anfang überhaupt nicht zusammenpasst
auch jetzt noch nicht so ganz und ich
bin auch nicht so ganz sicher ob das
wirklich so aufrichtig festen boden
steht aber wollen wir mal hoffen
es gibt leute die sagen dass jetzt
gerade auch die stunde der großaktionäre
ist die börse ist ja auch im plus würden
sie dem zustimmen dass die besonders
reichen jetzt noch reicher geworden sind
ja so einfach kann man es sich nicht
machen also wir hatten natürlich jetzt
extreme einbrüche bei den
vermögenswerten also da haben viele
menschen reiche menschen sehr viel geld
verloren
wir sind sehr viel weniger reich manchen
trifft es noch schlimmer er verliert
alles wenn er ein unternehmen hat und
das unternehmen ist jetzt insolvent ist
bankrott
das ist ein einziger wert hat alles rein
gesteckt dann ist das alles verloren
also es gibt natürlich jetzt auch wieder
menschen die investieren können und
jetzt im aufschwung wenn er denn kommt
vielleicht auch einiges verdienen können
aber der risikobereitschaft muss
natürlich auch entlohnt werden also sie
wird nicht sagen dass die oberen
zehntausend jetzt noch reicher geworden
dass die schere noch weiter auseinander
gegangen
das bleibt abzuwarten zunächst mal in
der finanzkrise ist es so dass die mit
den vermögenswerten ja am anfang am
meisten verlieren
und wer dann
wieder gewinnt im aufschwung dass sie
nicht immer die gleichen menschen viele
aktionäre und anleger gehören zu den
gewinnern der korona krise sie sind fein
raus
wer es aber nicht zu dicke hat der kann
wenigstens einen teil seines vermögens
sicherheitshalber in eine jahrhunderte
alte währung anlegen in das gute alte
gold seit jeher lebt der mensch das gold
manche sprechen dem gar magische
fähigkeiten zu auch heute noch sehnen
sich viele nach dem edlen metall
[Musik]
frage an den goldexperten joachim
goldberg der heißt wirklich so liegt
unsere gier nach gold etwa an der german
angst
ein bisschen besorgt über die zukunft
und wollen die zukunft natürlich
irgendwo unter kontrolle am vor allen
dingen wollen wir diejenigen team unter
kontrolle behalten
die jetzt nicht von heute auf morgen
passieren sondern die sich eventuell
negativ entwickeln könnten die kontrolle
behalten wenn sich alles negativ
entwickelt so wie zurzeit noch als wir
joachim goldberg treffen spielt das
virus noch keine große rolle
krisenzeiten hin oder her ist ein
goldschatz tatsächlich ein gutes
investment
dieser frage gehen wir in frankfurt am
main auf den grund der stadt der banken
und des goldes in den kellern der
bundesbank lager mehr als die hälfte des
deutschen goldschatzes 3400 tonnen
denn nicht nur privatpersonen auch
staaten investieren in gold
wenn sie als staat geld ausgeben
banknoten ausgeben da müssen sie
natürlich erst einmal akzeptanz und
vertrauen schaffen und das vertrauen
bekommen sie nur wenn sie etwas als
sicherheit als hintergrund dagegen
stellen was von allen menschen was von
möglichst vielen menschen akzeptiert ist
und das ist eben gold gewesen
noch ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
gilt in industriestaaten der
goldstandard für jede bank note und
münze die der staat in umlauf bringt
hält er eine gewisse menge an gold vor
außerdem ist der wechselkurs zwischen
geld und gold festgeschrieben
die idee jeder bürger kann auf der bank
sein geld gegen gold tauschen
doch im zwanzigsten jahrhundert drucken
die staaten immer mehr geld ohne ihren
goldschatz zu vergrößern
1971 gibt der us präsident die bindung
des dollar an die nationalen goldschatz
komplett auf das ende des goldstandards
sie gilt von richard nixon als
zentralbank ist natürlich die auflösung
des goldstandards ganz wichtig damit ich
flexibel bin damit ich auch flexibel auf
wirtschaftliche gegebenheiten reagieren
kann
gold als anlage verliert dadurch nicht
sein wert wir haben eine situation dass
selbst starten wieder interessiert sind
gold zu haben als alternative zu anderen
währung gold ist also immer noch in auch
ohne gold standard ist das seltene
metall bei dem staaten also weiterhin
begehrt
der deutsche goldschatz wächst nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg in nur 20 jahren aus
dem nichts auf über 3.000 tonnen
das deutsche wirtschaftswunder sorgt für
hohe einnahmen in fremden währungen
die tauschen die bundesbanker in gold um
und lagern einen großteil bei sicheren
notenbanken möglichst weit entfernt vom
eisernen vorhang in new york london und
paris
nach dem kalten krieg steht ein umzug
von new york nach frankfurt nichts im
weg doch es passiert bis 2012 nichts
das befeuert verschwörungstheorien das
heißt ein teil des goldes sei beck die
bundesbank muss handeln und beginnt den
größten goldbarren transport der welt
absolut geheim
bei der ankunft wird das gold exakt
untersucht nichts fehlt und alles echt
damit lagert seit 2017 zum ersten mal
gut die hälfte des deutschen goldes in
frankfurt für uns heißt es
eine sorge weniger
es geht um vorstellbar kai ich möchte
mir gerne vorstellen können als bürger
was hat ein staat eigentlich
erwirtschaftet was hat er überhaupt hat
dann nur buchgeld was mir nicht so gut
vorstellen kann oder bargeld der villa
von dem umlauf ist aber bei gold da weiß
ich ganz genau wovon wir sprechen und
der erfolg eines staates den kann man
natürlich in währungsreserven und
zahlungsbilanzen messen auch wenn gold
dabei ist dann sieht einfach besser aus
als wirtschafts und finanzexperte was
wünschen sie sich im umgang mit einer
solchen krise
ich denke was sehr wichtig war dass wir
im vorfeld stichwort schwarze null
stichwort schuldenbremse spielräume
aufgebaut haben
der staat konnte jetzt in deutschland
nur deswegen so stark eingreifen weil er
in der vergangenheit gespart hat weil er
in der vergangenheit darauf geachtet hat
dass die ausgaben nicht schneller als
das wachstum steigen und das also
schuldenquoten wieder zurückgehen und
diesen spielraum den müssen wir uns
irgendwann natürlich für zukünftige
krisen egal ob sie jetzt aufgrund einer
pandemie oder einer finanzkrise
auftreten wieder verschaffen
an welcher stelle müsste die finanzwelt
gerechter organisiert werden das system
muss im prinzip sich auf eigenen füßen
stehen und nicht auf eine druckluft
beatmung durch zentralbanken oder
regierungen angewiesen sein
das zweite ist dass man verlieren aber
die banken sind doch schon groß
too big to fail heißt es eben deswegen
werden sie ja druckluft beatmet denn
wenn sie wenn sie wenn sie wenn sie im
system haben das zum beispiel
funktioniert die volksbanken oder sowas
ja wo die eigentümer gleichzeitig auch
die kunden sind dann ist das ein
wesentlich stabileres system dieser
kooperative gedanke stabilisiert dieses
system in sich selbst ja wenn sie aber
eine bank haben die mit ganz geringem
eigenkapital 35 40 mal den einsatz quasi
im roulette spielt den sie da eigentlich
auf dem tisch hat ja dann ist es nicht
gesund und da muss man dagegen machen
also das stichwort heißt auf englisch
die leveraging muss man muss im prinzip
die bilanzsummen der banken schrumpfen
weil dann hat man zwei sachen einer zum
einen werden die banken
widerstandsfähiger und zum anderen
verlieren sie ihre verhandlungsmacht ja
also das ist ja man kann sich ja im
prinzip sind die sind große banken in
der lage
es starten zu erpressen ja weil das ihre
ist ja wir haben damals schon 2010 von
too big to fail gesprochen nach lehman
ja was wir heute haben ist nicht wir
haben nicht wir haben nicht mehr banken
was das ja eigentlich lösen für oder
sondern haben weniger banken die größer
sind ja also im prinzip hat sich die
problematik verschärft statt sich zu
entspannen um das ist was was man
angehen muss hat man irgendetwas aus dem
vorherigen finanzkrise gelernt kann man
das sagen ja also man hat ganz sicher
was gelernt aus den vorherigen
finanzkrisen also aus der finanzkrise
hat man zum beispiel gelernt dass die
banken besser auf krisen vorbereitet
sein müssen es kann nicht sein dass die
banken geld geld geld verdienen und
nicht ein teil davon zurücklegen für den
krisenfall und das hat man tatsächlich
gemacht und das war auch sehr gut so
also wir haben jetzt müssen die banken
fahren die großen banken die eben
systemrelevant sind müssen große
sicherheitspuffer also kapitalpolster
aufbauen und die zurücklegen das wenn
die krise kommt dass sie darauf
zurückgreifen können das hat man gelernt
und man hat gelernt schnelles eingreifen
schnelles handeln der regierungen und
der notenbanken ist in der krise enorm
wichtig das kann natürlich immer
passieren dass es einen finanzcrash oder
ein bankencrash auf uns zukommt ich
halte ihn für nicht ganz so
wahrscheinlich was gegen die banken
spricht das sprechen schon einige
faktoren gegen die banken einmal es
könnte sein dass für eine insolvenzwelle
bekommen dann fallen enorm viele kredite
aus kredite geld das die banken dann
nicht mehr sehen werden das wird sich
natürlich unheimlich belasten
gehen wir davon aus dass die wirtschaft
lange brach liegt dann leiden auch die
banken sehr stark darunter das ist alles
etwas was die banken belastet außerdem
haben sie seit jahren wegen der
niedrigen zinsen sehr wenig geld
verdient also die banken sind
grundsätzlich auch geschwächt
und die banken müssen sehr viel geld für
digitalisierung ausgeben also banken
stehen einfach insgesamt nicht so
wahnsinnig gut da sein einfach auch
probleme gehabt in den letzten jahren
was für die banken spricht ist dass die
kapitalpolster aufbauen mussten für
krisenzeiten und von denen können sie
jetzt zehren in der krise also wenn die
krise nicht zu lange dauert dann bin ich
ziemlich zuversichtlich dass die banken
das auch packen werden die korona krise
hat uns gezeigt wie international
vernetzt wir sind das virus kommt aus
china
von dort in die ganze welt und so geht
es auch mit waren und mit dem kapital
auch von hier vom frankfurter hafen aus
werden waren und kapital in die ganze
welt exportiert china exportiert vor
allem auch kapital in die ärmeren länder
doch die könne das geld kaum noch zu
bezahlen erst recht nicht nach der
korona krise ein neuer hafen in djibouti
eine eisenbahnlinie in kenia china
springt dort ein wo das kapital knapp
wird mittlerweile ist china der
bedeutendste kreditgeber für
entwicklungs und schwellenländer und das
nicht nur in afrika chinesische kredite
umspannen die ganze erde
am stärksten ist südamerika china
verschuldet mit einer gesamtsumme von
rund 140 milliarden us dollar
auf rang zwei folgt die region subsahara
mit knapp 136 milliarden und danach
asien mit knapp 107 milliarden das
weltweite finanzielle engagement chinas
erfüllt viele industrieländer mit
misstrauen berechtigt oder bank der
westen etwa nur um seinen einfluss für
diese bahnlinie hat sich kenia bei china
hoch verschuldet solche projekte
untermauern das misstrauen jetzt aber
können forscher den zweifel erstmals mit
fakten untermauern
das problem ist dass die verträge so
aufgesetzt sind dass es china rein
theoretisch möglich wäre staatseigentum
kenias zu finden
man denke etwa an den kenianischen hafen
an andere große öffentliche
infrastrukturen die china dann verlangen
könnte als fand als als sicherheit
gemeinsam mit zwei kollegen hat der
wirtschaftsprofessor christof trepesch
daten ausgewertet und erstmals einblick
in die verträge nehmen können
auch die kreditvergabe ist in china von
höchster stelle gelenkt anders als bei
der weltbank haben chinas verträge
marktkonditionen sie sind sozusagen
kommerzielle kredite mit hohen zinsen
außerdem bestehen die geldgeber aus
peking auf geheimhaltungsklausel für
internationale verträge sehr
ungewöhnlich aber das ist erst die
spitze des eisbergs was wir unsere
studie herausgefunden haben ist das etwa
die hälfte der kredite die china an
entwicklungsländer vergeben hat nicht
öffentlich bekannt war sind das heißt
wir sprechen da von versteckten schulden
und für die finanzstabilität eines
landes auch auf globaler perspektive ist
es absolut fundamental zu wissen wie
hoch die schulden eines landes sind und
wie die konditionen dieser verschuldung
aussieht und das ist im fall der
chinesischen kritiker einfach nicht
gegeben werden also ein riesiges
transparenz problem länder wie
turkmenistan die republik kongo oder
venezuela stehen vollständig bei china
in der kreide
der sudan beispielsweise hat china
verbindlichkeiten von mehr als 70% kenia
fast 40 und pakistan immerhin fast 30
prozent
die sinologin noras ausweg art von der
organisation urgewald räumt zwar ein
dass china die länder nicht gezielt in
eine schuldenfalle treiben aber die
ungewöhnlich harten kreditkonditionen
seien problematisch das sind meistens
kredite die die länder 30 bis 50 jahre
binden und trotzdem sind die
rückzahlungsbedingungen nicht so dass
sie langfristig angelegt sind das heißt
das ist eine spezielle eine besonderheit
der chinesischen kredite
diese oft sehr großen kredite für zum
beispiel infrastrukturmaßnahmen müssen
teilweise relativ kurzfristig
zurückgezahlt werden was dann diese
länder in die schuldenfalle treibt mit
den stolzen wachstumsraten chinas ging
in der vergangenheit eine großzügige
kreditvergabe einher
aber was jetzt wenn die wirtschaft ins
straucheln gerät ein großes risiko was
ich sehe ist nicht einfach dass china
immer weitere kredite vergibt sondern
sich von den internationalen
kreditvergabe zurück zieht und das würde
für die besonders verschuldeten ländern
zu großen problemen führt woher wir
können die jetzt die sich kredite gegen
china refinanzieren wo wir kommen die an
frisches geld wenn ich ihn da plötzlich
wegfällt und das könnte für einige
länder bedeuten dass sie in
finanzprobleme geraten und
möglicherweise in eine schuldenkrise
geraten
sri lanka ein flughafen den niemand
braucht finanziert aus chinesischen
krediten
hier ist noch nie ein flugzeug gestartet
oder gelandet warten heißt es hier nur
für das personal und dieser flughafen
ist nicht die einzige luftnummer der
chinesischen kreditpolitik und so
verschulden sich viele
entwicklungsländer auch bei uns dort
schulden erlassen
gibt es so gut wie gar nicht viele in
ärmeren staaten droht jetzt mit der
korona krise die pleite der finanzcrash
ein beispiel mosambik
mosambik 2009/10 zwei wirbelstürme
richten große verwüstungen an
hunderte menschen sterben eine halbe
million wird obdachlos
fast 20 jahre zuvor auch damals wüteten
zyklone brachten das vom bürgerkrieg
geschwächte verarmte und verschuldete
land an den finanziellen abgrund
aber es gab auch hoffnung
eine große initiative forderte hilfe für
die ärmsten länder
und es kommt tatsächlich zum
internationalen schuldenerlass mosambik
profitiert mit am meisten auf über sechs
milliarden us dollar verzichten die
gläubiger am ende trotzdem ist mosambik
heute wieder hoch verschuldet wegen
eines skandals um illegale aufgenommene
staatskredite kam es sogar teilweise zu
einem zahlungsausfall hat der
schuldenerlass nichts bewirkt nach der
entschuldung mosambiks ist die
verschuldung hauptsächlich deshalb
angestiegen weil mosambik einen sehr
hohen bedarf an
infrastrukturinvestitionen aufweist und
dafür das geld im inland alleine nicht
aufbringen kann
das geht vielen ärmeren
entwicklungsländern so dass es kein muss
am big spezifisches phänomen christine
rehbein arbeitet in düsseldorf für das
bündnis erlassjahr.de das ist
hervorgegangen aus der initiative erlass
jahr 2004 beobachtet und begleitet man
die entwicklung seither der
internationale währungsfonds warnt es
schon 2018 vor einer zu hohen
verschuldung einiger afrikanischer
staaten
mosambik hat dabei noch ein spezielles
problem
unser weg ist aktuell bereits in einer
schuldenkrise die ist maßgeblich dadurch
entstanden dass 2016 im verborgenen
aufgenommene illegale kredite ans
tageslicht kam
die unter umgehung der verfassung und
des parlaments aufgenommen worden sind
und als die an die öffentlichkeit kam da
ist mosambik zahlungsunfähig geworden
und in eine schuldenkrise geraten
neue schuldenkrisen werfen auch die
frage nach erneutem schuldenerlass auf
christine rehbein plädiert grundsätzlich
für die schaffung einer geordneten
staatsinsolvenz
das kann ein schiedsgerichtshof bei den
vereinten nationen sein
das kann sich aber auch in einem
informellen adhoc bereich abspielen
wichtig ist dass drei prinzipien im
rahmen dieses verfahrens eingehalten
werden das ist zum einen dass alle
gläubiger in diesem verfahren mit am
tisch sitzen
das ist dass sowohl die schulden
situationen als auch später die
entscheidung über den schuldenerlass von
unabhängigen instanzen getroffen werden
im fall von mosambik gibt es immerhin
auch lichtblicke
2010 wurden im land große gasvorkommen
entdeckt das könnte die lösung der
probleme sein kann das für uns
gefährlich werden die hohe schuldenquote
von anderen staaten
natürlich sind schulden auch in den
schwellenländern sehr hoch oder köln
steigen nach dieser krise aber trotzdem
unsere wichtigsten handelspartner
handelspartner sind zunächst mal die
schwellenländer in asien die usa und
eure unserer europäischen partner
solange es dort gutgeht denke ich ist
die situation für uns auch gut im
internationalen ausblick es gibt länder
die von einer infektionswelle besonders
stark betroffen werden könnten wenn wir
an lateinamerika oder afrika denken aber
im großen zusammenhang denke ich hängt
unsere wirtschaft nicht so stark an
diesen ländern wir haben schulden
basiert ist das schreiben dass sie das
wirtschaftssystem und das müssen sie
sich vorstellen wie nun ja also dieser
ofen der der muss laufen und wird damit
dieser ofen läuft muss man da was
reinschmeißen und was wir machen müssen
ist schulden ranschmeißen das ist sowas
funktioniert du dich und ich möchte mir
fällt nur eine zahl ein zum beispiel den
usa 2016 war es glaube ich sie haben 18
dollar gebraucht um einen dollar
wachstum zu erzeugen
eine heizung mit so einem wirkungsgrad
würden sie sich nicht kaufen also wenn
man kann natürlich die systemfrage
stellen aber ich stelle sie nicht so
radikal dass ich sage wir müssen jetzt
das ist ganz ganz zu abschaffen oder so
sondern es geht im prinzip darum diesen
diesen kapitalismus den wir haben den
wohlstand den wir haben und die
möglichkeiten die es bietet ins 21
jahrhundert zu transportieren und da
sehe ich große defizite wenn man sich
auf theorien verlässt die aus den 20er
30er 40er jahren stammen mehrheitlich
österreichischen schule oder die
einfache frage droht nach coroner der
finanzcrash da sagen sie wenn ich sie
richtig verstanden habe nein
nach dieser corona krise nicht was dann
kommen kann das wissen wir alle nicht
aber jetzt ist das system stabil ich
würde es noch subtiler formuliert droht
droht der finanzcrash ja aber man kann
natürlich auch eine drohung abwenden
stehen sie also der es gibt große holen
wo ich mich jetzt wieder sowie war ja
eher droht wird es einen finanz crash
gegeben ist eine andere frage als droht
der finanzcrash droht der finanzcrash
kann er abgewandt werden durch aktionen
von notenbanken und regierungen kein
problem so wie das derzeit geschieht weg
st
der unterschied zu anderen krisen ist
dass es eine völlig unverschuldet krise
war also wir haben kein
vertrauensproblem mit den banken wiener
finanzkrise zum beispiel oder in der als
internetblase geplatzt ist und die
unternehmen einfach man einfach ganz
falsche wetten eingegangen ist an den
aktienmärkten diesmal haben wir es mit
einer pandemie zu tun an der keiner
schuld ist und insofern dass das gute an
dieser krise sie ist wenn wir die
krankheit bewältigt haben dann ist sie
auch wirtschaftlich zu bewältigen und
die börse und die anleger haben doch
überwiegend auch vertrauen in die
regierungen ja ist das so ja ich glaube
dass die korona krise schon auch gezeigt
hat dass die staaten die die krise gut
bewältigt haben das dann da ein gewisses
vertrauen den regierungen gegenüber
gebracht wurde also das glaube ich ist
eine folge der krise dass wieder ein
wenig mehr vertrauen in die staaten
gebracht wird als das vielleicht vorher
der fall war dass sie wirtschaftlich
bereits sind viel zu geben und das ist
dass die staaten die die krise wie
gesagt gut bewältigt haben ein
ordentliches krankheits system auf die
beine gestellt haben dass sie den
menschen richtig sagen wann sie zu hause
bleiben müssen um sie zu schützen ich
glaube da ist eine stärkere bindung
wieder entstanden zwischen staat und
bevölkerung wichtig für die zukunft ist
wir dürfen uns da nicht übernehmen wir
müssen schauen dass alles tragfähig
bleibt droht nach corona der finanzcrash
die experten sagen uns stand jetzt nein
wir haben viel aus den vergangenen
finanzkrise gelernt
die regierungen handeln die banken sind
robust die notenbanken steuert es ist
richtig
mit viel geld die wirtschaft wieder
anzukurbeln
allerdings wir könnten jetzt die gunst
der stunde nutzen und massiv in die
zukunft investieren zb in eine kohärente
klimapolitik und in die digitalisierung
nur so machen wir unsere wirtschaft auch
langfristig stabil
[Musik]